MaMartine Michel et Paul sont ac
nonous. Bonsoir à v vous trois.
LeLe recul, certains disaient
auaujourd'hui que c'était écrit
dadans le ciel, mais toujours e-
ilil qu'il a reculé aujourd'hui
susur cette taxe pour les noms
vavaccinés. La manifestation a
pepesé dans la balance. Il dit e
c'c'est le moment maintenant
d'd'oublier ce qu'on a dit est e
rerefaire une cohésion sociale.e
vovous laisse entendre M. Legaut
etet les oppositions et on revit
enen parler.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Dans la balance, aujourd'hu,
jeje pense que c'est important
dede protéger la paix sociale,
dede protéger la cohésion socia,
dede rassembler les Québécois.
DoDonc, je pense que
lala contribution santé aurait
pupu aider à  êtrtre un incitatf
popour certaines personnes.
OnOn voit une grogne grandir.
J'J'ai vu, évidemment, la réactn
dedes partis d'opposition.
DoDonc, je pense que j'ai aussi
unune responsabilité, au-delà
dede protéger la sécurité
dedes Québécois en incitant
leles Québécois à s se faire
vavacciner, j'ai aussi une
reresponsabilité que tout
cece monde-là r réapprenne
àà v vivre ensemble.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe, PLQ
- - Le directeur de la santé
pupublique démissionne.
LeLe premier ministre nonous are
avavec une idée, une idée qui et
irirréfléchie, pour laquelle
ilil n'a pas consulté. Mais
s's'il a consulté, c'est peut-êe
unune maison de sondages.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Cette taxe broche à f foin-à
a a jamais été rien d'autre
ququ'une stratégie politique.
CÇa aurait ajouté aucun lit
dadans nos hôpipitaux, ça aurait
raramené aucune infirmièrere
dadans notre systèmeme public.
JOJOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole
dudu PQ en matièrere de santé
- - Le premier ministre aime
bebeaucoup dire que les Québécos
sosont tannés. Ouiui, les Québés
sosont tannés. Ils sont tannés
dedes incohérences, ils sont
tatannés de l'improvisation,
dedes ballons d'essai.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - On a mis en place le passept
vavaccinal, qu'on a élargi,
onon avait lancé l'idée d'une
cocontribution santé, mais on vt
rarassembler les Québécois.
- - Voilà. . Vous avez tout ent.
MaMartine, M. Legault dit que ce
n'n'est plus à i inciter le plue
momonde possible, mais la cohésn
sosociale devient un élément qul
fafaut prendre en compte.
- - Ça prend des appuis aussi pr
memener ce type de projet de lo.
C'C'est ce qui était prévu pour
cecette semaine.
JeJe vais vous dire deux choses
llà-d-dessus qui sont liées.
D'D'abord le vent a tourné. Il a
trtrois semaines M. Legault avat
ququand mêmeme l'appui de son cs
popour aller de l'avant avec de
tetelles mesures.
EtEt le cholski que ce prêtt
obobsessionnel qui a eu lieu jei
etet vendredi en virtuel a monté
ququ'ils avaient changé de cap.
LeLes caucus, sont l'ce sont les
yeyeux et les oreilles du premir
miministre sur le terrain. J'aiu
vevent de ces discussions en fin
dede semaine.
J'J'ai poussé un peu la recherce
popour me rendre compte que
bebeaucoup de députés n'étaient
plplus d'accord avec ces mesure.
MMêmeme il y a quelqu'un qui m'a
didit : le premier ministre avat
mmêmeme l'air surpris du chanant
dede cap de son caucus : il se
reretrouve dans une situation ùu
ilil n'a plus son caucus derrièe
lului, il n'a pas les partis
d'd'opposition, ils y a certains
éléléments de la santé publique
auaussi qui ont dit publiquement
ququ'il n'était pas certain, les
miministres du les emplois de
prpresse aujourd'hui n'avaient s
tetellement l'air heureux de cee
ididée. Alors la situation c'est
quque tu t'en vas en année
élélectorale dans une situatioùu
tutu vas affronter un vent de
faface. Ce que tu veux en années
élélectorales et distribuer des
bobonbons, paramètrtres des mess
cocoercitives.
- - Donc ça ne vous a pas étonné
ououtre mesure non plus.
- - Non parce qu'il y avait des
prproblèmemes aussi littéralemet
tetechnique. Les 10 % des gens s
vavaccinés, ce ne sont pas tous
dedes gens qui sont des amis de
ceceux qui sont devant le
PaParlement à O Ottawa aujourd'.
IlIl y avait toutes sortes de
momonde là-d-dedans, des sans-a,
dedes gens qui ne parlent pas
frfrançais et anglais. À un momt
dodonné s'arrêteter très s compé
dede faire cela. En plus on veut
avavoir un systèmeme de santé qi
esest là p pour punir plutôt t e
popour soigner?
C'C'est ququand mêmeme une quesn
ququ'il faut se poser dans ce
gegenre de situation. Et est-ce
ququ'on veut que le ministèrereu
rerevenu puisse jouer dadans nos
dodossiers de santé? Il y a des
poportes parfois qui doivent
rerester fermées.
- - Surtout qu'on a réalisé que
c'c'était pas applicable ou à tt
lele moins que c'était applicab,
mamais que ça allait arriver trp
tatard parce qu'il y avait deux
ararguments en fonction de cela.
LeLe premier était celui de la
cocohésion sociale. Ironiquement
mamaintenant c'est devenu
l'l'argument contre mais à
l'l'époque on disait que c'était
jujustement au nom de la cohésin
sosociale qu'il fallait serrer a
vivis au nom vacciné. C'était le
prpremier argument. L'autre
arargument était de dire que ça
alallait inciter des gens se fae
vavacciner.
SaSauf que cette mesure
nénécessitait un projet de loi.
DoDonc on a besoin de l'appui de
l'l'opposition pour que son étue
sese passait rapidement. Mais si
vovous avez un projet de loi, vs
vovous battez contre l'oppositi,
vovous finissez seulement par le
vivin adopté en mai ou en juin
prprochain alors que la cinquièe
vavague sera derrièrere nous, qe
esest l'utilité de cela
fifinalement? C'est quelque choe
ququi est réactif. Ce n'était ps
foforcément applicable ou du mos
apapplicable pour êtrtre utile.
- - La grogne dont parlait
MoMonsieur Legault, elle est
réréelle. On l'a vu à O Ottawa.y
avavait quand mêmeme beaucoup de
momonde samedi.
QuQuébec, on verra. Ça ne s'est
papas produit mais on ne peut ps
êêtrtre devin. Monsieur Legaulte
veveut pas mettre de l'huile sur
lele feu.
IlIl y a son caucus mais il sent
auaussi qu'il mettrait de l'huie
susur le feu.
- - En plus il commence à
dédéconfiner.
IlIl met en place un calendrier.
MaMais les nouvelles ne sont pas
mamauvaises. On s'en va vraiment
vevers la lumièrere au bout du
tutunnel. Il y a quand mêmeme ue
opopportunité pour lui quiui est
dedevant lui.
AlAlors aussi bien garder cela
cacalme. On va voir aussi ce qui
vava se passer à Q Québec samed.
- - Vous parlez d'assouplisseme.
JeJe vous fais entendre les pars
d'd'opposition, Éric Duhaime qui
évévidemment veut plus
d'd'assouplissement, mêmeme les
auautres qui disent : il serait
tetemps d'aller plus vite. On au
cece film à p plusieurs reprise.
PaParfois c'est plus de mesure,
paparfois c'est moins.
EÉRIC DUHAIME, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Québec
- - On peut pas continuer
àà e empêchcher le Québec de vie
popour sauver le systèmeme de sé
ététernellement. Le systèmeme
dede santé est là p pour sauver
leles Québécois, c'est pas
leles Québécois qui sont supposs
papasser deux ans de leur vie
susur off pour sauver un système
dede santé, là..
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Arrivez avec un plan qui di:
VoVoici, à u un certain nombre
d'd'hospitalisations, puis compe
tetenu du retour des travailleus
ququi étaient malades aussi, là,
bibien, à t tel moment, on va pr
tetel geste, puis à t tel momen,
onon va poser tel geste,
dede manièrere à c ce que la
coconfiance, l'adhésion revienn.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Dans le cas du Parti
coconservateur du Québec,
jeje suis pas surpris.
DaDans le cas du Parti québécoi,
jeje suis surpris. De dire qu'on
n'n'a pas le droit de mettre
dedes incitatifs pour que les gs
sese fassent vacciner, puis évir
d'd'engorger nos hôpipitaux,
çaça me surprend. C'est pas le
PaParti québécois que je connai.
PuPuis, quand j'entends le Parti
ququébécois, puis mêmeme Québec
sosolidaire dire, tantôt,t,
quque selon eux, il y a trop
dede restrictions, bien, je troe
çaça irresponsable.
- - Il y a ce débat aussi. Toure
tatable sur est-ce qu'on devrait
acaccélérer ou non. On a annoncé
popour le 14 février les gyms, s
papas pour les adultes entre
auautres.
- - Je note que les choses
évévoluent vite dans l'opinion
pupublique et aussi dans les
popositions des oppositions.
EnEn novembre et en décembre, on
rereprochait au gouvernement
d'd'avoir trop rapidement annoné
dedes relâchchements pour Noël t
d'd'avoir été trop lent pour
seserrer les mesures avec
l'l'arrivée de la cinquièmeme v.
EtEt maintenant c'est le
cocontraire. On dit avant vous
ététiez trop laxiste, maintenant
vovous êtetes trop restrictif il
fafaut relâchcher.
L'L'autre chose qui est demandée
c'c'est ajoutée de la
prprévisibilité.
IlIl y a quand mêmeme des limità
lala prévisibilité que l'on peut
avavoir. En accaparant au retour
enen classe.
OnOn commence à  êtrtre capablen
memesurer les conséquences. Mais
ilil faut êtrtre vigilant par
rarapport à ç ça.
EtEt aussi par rapport aux autrs
memesures.
OnOn relâchche, on observe les s
etet ensuite relâchche un peu p.
OnOn ne peut pas avoir un
cacalendrier très s précis mais
dodonner un petit avant-goût t e
prprévisibilité, je pense que oi
llà-d-dessus il peut y avoir
coconsensus.
- - Que pensez-vous de cette
vavalse?
- - Dans un monde idéal on ne
feferait pas ça mais le variant
OmOmicron ne nous a pas mis dans
unun monde idéal non plus. Et en
plplus les restrictions n'ont ps
lele mêmeme effet pour tout le
momonde. Il y en a pour qui c'et
bibien important que les gyms
sosoient ouverts, d'autres les
rerestaurants.
OnOn ne peut pas faire consensus
avavec ça.
OnOn voit par exemple dans les
ararts de la scènene, il y a des
gegens qui disent ouvrir 50 % de
mama salle, ça ne vaut pas la
pepeine, je ne l'ouvrirai pas. t
popour d'autres ça vaut la pein.
C'C'est vraiment difficile de
cocontenter tout le monde. Toute
momonde va êtrtre contente quand
totoutes les restrictions seront
paparties. On sait tout ce qu'il
pepeut y avoir une autre vague t
ilil va falloir confiner à
nonouveau.
- - Il y a des tensions ambiant.
C'C'est pas tout le monde qui a
vévécu les cinq vagues de la fin
dede la mêmeme façon. C'est sûre
leles restaurateurs sont rendusà
lala quatrièmeme fermeture.
C'C'est quelque chose qu'ils ont
vévécu. Il y avait un titre très
inintéressant dans La Presse en
fifin de semaine sur les
tetechniciens de la Seine, la
vavague de suicides chez ces ge-
llà..
OnOn prenait pas mal consciencee
cece que certaines personnalités
vévécues au cours de ces
didifférentes vagues. Et ce sont
sosouvent les mêmemes personnesi
sosont touchées vagues aprèss
vavague.
AlAlors quand la courbe commencà
dedescendre, c'est sûr r que la
prpression commence à a augmentr
popour qu'on puisse déconfiner
dadavantage.
EtEt les partis d'opposition
jojouent dans ce film parce que
eueux aussi dans leur
cicirconscription ils entendent
bebeaucoup de choses.
MaMais on se rend compte cinq
vavagues plus tard qu'on n'est
pepeut-êtrtre pas encore sorti e
l'l'auberge. On a maintenant le
sosou variant de Omicron qui
ararrivent. Va-t-on avoir une
reremontée des cas?
OnOn n'a pas vraiment le choix e
susuivre sa jour après s jour et
esessayer de donner un peu d'air
jojour après s jour quand ça ree
unun peu.
- - On ne peut pas avoir des
cacartes métriques avec tel seul
exexactement. Enfin.
- - Un petit commentaire rapide,
l'l'institut de recherches
popolitiques publiques a montré
quque depuis le début de la
papandémie le Québec est quand
mmêmeme une des problèmemes less
rerestrictifs sinon la plus
rerestrictif par rapport au
rerestaurant, mêmeme si les
rerestaurateurs ont fait des
efefforts. On voit qu'on se
dédémarquait en ce sens par note
sésévérité à l l'endroit des
rerestaurateurs.
- - En est l'administration la
plplus restrictif pour les
rerestaurants effectivement. Jee
cocomprends mêmeme pas avec les
EÉtats-Unis. La question était
poposée avec M. Legault. Est-ce
ququ'on ne pourrait pas ouvrir e
1313 plutôt t que le 14. Envoi s
ststades pleins.
AsAssouplissement...
jeje ne veux pas m'en aller!
ErErin O'Toole, qu'est-ce qui se
papasse?
LLà, , on est tenté de dire quee
sosont les plus à d droite, les
coconservateurs sociaux qui se
rérévoltent, mais c'est plus
cocomplexe. La révolte et peut-
êêtrtre mêmeme plus profonde que
cecela. Mêmeme des gens pas pari
leles conservateurs sociaux qui
n'n'en veulent plus d'Erin
O'O'Toole.
- - Il a de problèmeme. Il a un
prproblèmeme avec les conservats
sosociaux à c ce moment-ci, mail
y y a aussi le problèmeme de s'e
apappuyé sur eux pour êtrtre
reredevenu chef du parti et aprs
çaça dire qu'il faut qu'on s'en
aiaille au centre. Et la crise s
cacamionneurs comme exacerber tt
çaça, une espècece de réputatioe
gigirouette. Je ne rencontrerai
papas les leaders du mouvement,
ououi je vais les rencontrer.
C'C'est ce que les gens à u un
momoment donné dans le caucus
coconservateur, les gens surtout
dede les plus conservatrices mas
ququand mêmeme, d'autres aussi i
disent que ça n'a plus de bon
sesens.
CeCe parti n'est pas très s genl
avavec ses chefs quand tilber :
AnAndrew Scheer en sait quelque
chchose.
MaMais à l la fin, Erin O'Toolea
pepeut-êtrtre contribué à s son
mamalheur pas mal. Switch dans
vovotre esprit, c'est réglé,
dedemain il n'est plus cher?
- - Mêmeme s'il gagne avec diso5
%,%, 60 % du vote, vous ne voulz
papas êtrtre chef du parti s'ila
4040 % de vos députés qui vous
memettent des couteaux dans le
dodos. La machine infernale est
enenclenchée.
- - Et déjà, , avant mêmeme la e
dudu vote, si on regarde son do,
ilil n'y a pas beaucoup de peaut
ilil y a plus de métal dedans. l
y y a déjà p pas mal de couteau.
ChChaque journée quand il prend
unune position, il y a d'autres
dédéputés qui disent plus ou mos
lele contraire.
DoDonc c'est une mission
imimpossible si Erin O'Toole
esessaie de plaire aux gens pluà
drdroite dans son caucus, il est
dédéjà t trop tard.
EtEt il va dire des choses qui
vovont l'empêchcher de gagner. s
ilil dit le contraire, il fallat
mémécontenter.
SoSon erreur aussi qui frustre
bebeaucoup de gens qui sont peu-
êêtrtre moins associés à l la de
réréformiste qui fait qu'ils ont
l'l'impression que Erin O'Toole
chchange souvent d'opinion.
DoDonc s'il était constant et sl
dédéplaît t à l la base, il ne e
plplus beaucoup d'arguments en a
fafaveur.
- - La question qui se pose c'et
: : est-ce que quelqu'un quelque
papart pourrait rallier ses deux
ouou trois courants différents
chchez les bleus ou bien si on e
sesera pas inévitablement devant
unun parti divisé pour encore
plplusieurs années?
EtEt M. Trudeau qui va êtrtre mt
dede rire pendant plusieurs
anannées.
- - c'est possible que ce soit .
StStephen Harper a été capable e
tetenir les parties ensemble et
vivisiblement il l'a fait et le
nanaturel est revenu au galop. l
a a réussi à g garder cela en p.
C'C'est sûr r que Erin O'Toole a
papas narratif tout au long de n
leadadership où il a été capable
dede garder les équipes ensembl.
IlIl a réécrit sa plate-forme
élélectorale en pleine campagne
élélectorale pour plaire à u unà
l'l'autre.
MMêmeme chose avec les camionne.
AlAlors ce n'était pas très s se
cocomme leadership.
- - mes Stephen Harper à l l'épe
lala marque libérale s'était
efeffondrée, il y avait le
scscandale des commandites, il
avavait effectivement réussi
l'l'union de la droite. Mais le
cocontexte est différent. Les
lilibéraux ne sont pas amochés
cocomme l'étaient les libéraux à
l'l'époque. S'il part demain, il
vava falloir qu'il pense à l le
reremplacer.
CoComment vous voyez ça Michel?
- - Ce ne sera pas simple parce
quque ce qui est arrivé au cours
dedes derniers mois, depuis
l'l'élection ou un peu avant,
c'c'est que les sociaux
coconservateurs sont devenus pls
foforts dans le parti. La goutte
ququi a fait déborder le vase pr
plplusieurs, et c'est d'ailleurs
susur la lettre du député qui
dedemande ce mode de leadership,
c'c'est accepté le projet de loà
l'l'unanimité sur l'interdiction
dedes thérapies de conversion.Ç,
lala droite conservatrice de la
papatrie. Ça, c'est l'élément
nonouveau. Ces gens-là s sont
mamaintenant devenus carrément s
enennemis de M. O'Toole. Ils sot
plplus nombreux qu'avant.
CÇa a toujours été difficile de
mamaintenir les deux groupes
enensemble, mêmeme sous Monsieur
MuMulroney.
IlIls se sont séparés à u un mot
dodonné ils sont revenus ensembe
paparce qu'ils se sont rendus
cocompte qu'il ne prendrait jams
lele pouvoir s'il ne finissait
papas.
MaMais est-ce qu'il y a un Stepn
HaHarper ou un Brian Mulroney qi
atattend dans les coulisses? No.
- - J'ai l'impression que le sel
ciciment pour les factions
opopposées de ce parti, c'est
l'l'attrait du pouvoir.
EtEt donc il faudrait un chef qi
esest suffisamment populaire das
leles sondages pour que les gens
enentrevoient le retour au pouvr
etet accepte de mettre de côtété
cecertains désaccords. Mais tant
ququ'ils auront l'impression
ququ'ils sont dans l'opposition,
ilils vont dire j'ai mieux diree
quque je pense dans le position
quque de me censurer si ça ne me
rarapproche pas plus d'une
poposition de ministre.
AÀ l'époque de Stephen Harper
c'c'était un nouveau parti
coconservateur qui résultait dea
fufusion de la droite réformiste
ququi est devenue le parti pris
coconservateur progressiste. One
didisait qu'on allait donner une
chchance à l la fusion.
MaMais ce n'est plus le context.
IlIls ont essayé, ça a fonction.
CÇa ne fonctionne plus.
EtEt ils y en a qui ont bien le
cocoup d'essayer autre chose.
L'L'heure est plus à l la mutine
ququ'à l l'unité en ce moment.
SwSwitch et on voit dans ces
momoments de crise, et vous parz
dede Brian Mulroney, on pourrait
auaussi parler de Jean Charest,
cocomment un leader va jouer avc
soson caucus, va jouer en équipe
etet qu'il a besoin de son équi.
PoPour traverser une tempêtete,l
fafaut que tu donnes envie à t t
lele monde jouer avec toi.
- - Steven Harper l'avait fait.
IlIl y a eu 10 ans, ça été trèss
didifficile de rallier par exeme
leles vieux du Reform, Debrah
GrGrey, des députés qui voulaiet
sosortir du parti conservateur
paparce qu'ils étaient plus à
drdroite. Finalement Stephen
HaHarper a réussi à l les tenir
enensemble avec Peter MacKay. Ms
auaussitôt t il a été par